en los últimos días se ha demostrado que
la eficacia de esas defensas antiaéreas
que han obrado con bastante precisión en
la ciudad de kiev en las últimas semanas
que ha sido atacada especialmente desde
mayo en múltiples ocasiones no tiene la
misma efectividad en otras regiones del
país no hay suficiente defensa antiaérea
para desplegar en otras partes o en la
totalidad de este país que es inmenso
esto se ha demostrado en los últimos
días especialmente en la ciudad de kribi
de donde es originario el presidente
bolo dormir selenski que está en el
centro del país en la provincia de deni
Pro allí el martes pasado ataques con
misiles dejaban 11 personas muertas y 28
heridas en un ataque a un edificio
Residencial pero también a una fábrica
vecina esta madrugada se volvió a
repetir este ataque con cuatro misiles
uno de ellos fue interceptado pero de
ellos alcanzaron sus objetivos las
autoridades regionales dicen que
alcanzaron unas fábricas que no eran
militares y donde no dejaron Muertos
pero este mismo tipo de ataques también
se ha realizado en las últimas días en
la ciudad de Odessa y en esta provincia
lo que demuestra que obviamente Ucrania
no tiene esa capacidad para desplegar
defensas ante aéreas no por lo menos en
la misma capacidad que tiene en esta
capital kiev donde nos encontramos y
esto llega en un momento en el que
siguen las batallas en el frente de
batalla en la contraofensiva
especialmente en estos 600 kilómetros de
la provincia de saporilla la
viceministra de defensa aseguraba que
estas luchas siguen siendo feroces
Aunque algunas otras versiones dicen que
Ucrania habría ralentizado estos ataques
en busca de esos puntos débiles de la
defensa rusa y se espera que vuelvan
comenzar un ataque mucho más feroz no
solamente en saporilla sino en el don
Bass en los próximos días